ganz kurz vor dem nächsten dürre sommer
diskutiert deutschland über e autos
können sie das klima retten und wie
sauber sind sie wirklich
tatsächlich haben wir deutsche politiker
und autohersteller beim thema
elektromobilität jahrelang gepennt jetzt
heißt es nur noch panisch softies
freunde ja klar
vw und co haben mit einer gesunden
portion krimineller energie den diesel
versenkt da muss ein ersatzprodukt her
findet auch der wirtschaftsminister und
zitiert ein bekanntes sprichwort
gerade in den städten gibt es riesige
einsatz märkte für elektrofahrzeuge und
ja und wenn die großen
automobilhersteller sich nicht beeilen
und werden kleinere ihnen ganze stücke
kuchen vom brot nehmen
[Applaus]
so sagt man jedenfalls bei altmaiers zu
hause
elektromobilität löst schon probleme
aber sicher nicht alle denn leider
verursacht allein die herstellung dieser
erfahrenen und zum teil schweren
batterien wahnsinnig viel co2 nach einer
aktuellen volkswagen studie müsste man
100.000 kilometer fahren bis man
sauberer ist als ein verbrenner vom
kohleanteil im deutschen strommix mal
ganz zu schweigen
trotzdem am auto führt kein weg vorbei
langfristig auch wenn manche männer
immer noch fremdeln ein rasierapparat
auf vier rädern den wird irgendwie jeder
mal zusammen nageln können nämlich
elektroauto aber es ist das
entscheidende
wie intelligent dieses fahrzeug ist und
noch entscheidender waren entwickeln wir
endlich einen intelligenten
verkehrsminister aber
doch
das wollen wir nicht umstimmen im moment
das ist fakt sind elektroautos leider
erschreckend oft zweit oder sogar
drittwagen von besserverdienern die in
der stadt wohnen also genau da wo die
fahrzeugdichte zu hoch ist ich verrate
ihnen jetzt mal ein schreckliches
geheimnis meine damen und herren um die
klimaziele von paris noch irgendwie zu
schaffen reicht es leider nicht alle
autos elektrisch zu machen dann brauchen
wir in deutschland tatsächlich wir
brauchen mehr fahrräder besseren
nahverkehr wo ich höre bleibt unsere
quote bei den männlichen zuschauern geht
gerade brutal in den keller
schnell macht mal was
[Musik]
willkommen zurück meine herren ja auf
wiedersehen liebe filme nichts finden es
ist ich weiß es ist nicht populär das zu
sagen aber gerade in den großstädten
gerade in den städten ist e mobilität
allein eben nicht die antwort morgens
halb zehn in deutschland wir sitzen
alleine in tonnen schweren autos und
fahren in schrittgeschwindigkeit zur
arbeit vorbei bald sitzen wir alle
alleine in tonnen schweren elektro autos
und fahren in schrittgeschwindigkeit zur
arbeit viel geiler e mobilität noch
schneller ist nur die sogenannte e
mobilität die mobilität da geht was
sein
ja gehen je gehört und die deutschen
autohersteller fordern jetzt jede woche
lautstark noch viel mehr subventionen
für ihre elektroautos wohlgemerkt schirm
die in den letzten jahren trotz diesel
beschiss gigantische gewinne eingefahren
haben vielleicht sollten die erstmal
ihre autoverkäufer schulen in sachen e
auto
denn so richtig im thema sind die noch
nicht ihr echtes verkaufsgespräch der
ist aber leise man hört ja gar nichts
das liegt daran dass der i3 kein motor
mehr hat keinen motor
das ist im endeffekt so wie bei einem
ventilator der hat auch kein motor ja
der ventilator dreht sich auch nur wenn
man rein pustet macht man frau merkel
und wo wir gerade beim meckern sind e
mobilität kostet höchstwahrscheinlich
auch arbeitsplätze weil man viel weniger
leute braucht um einen rasierapparat auf
rädern zusammenzubauen
andererseits entstehen natürlich auch
völlig neue jobs elektroautos sind
derartig leise dass da immer einer
mitfahren muss für den sound
[Applaus]
fotos
werden sie bald immer öfter hören ich
studiere bäume bäume auf bachelor
autoindustrie und groko setzen im moment
finde ich zu ausschließlich auf die
karte e autos dabei gibt es echte
alternativen biomethan zum beispiel
damit betreibt die stadt augsburg ihre
komplette busflotte eine erprobte
klimaneutrale technik bei der man
letztlich kein scherz mit strom fährt
viel große ballen stroh liefern so viel
biogas wie ein durchschnittlicher pkw
pro jahr verbraucht
ja wo ist ihr euch vier ballen für ein
jahr fahren stroh also erneuerbare
energie ein
ein abfallprodukt der gesellschaft wenn
man alle stroh was ungenutzt auf unseren
feldern vormonat in biosprit verwandeln
würde könnte man damit 7 millionen pkw
betreiben trotzdem hat die groko durch
neue verordnung das geschäft der
biomethan produzenten weniger lukrativ
gemacht warum da kann ich wirklich
nichts zu sagen das ist nicht in meinem
verantwortungsbereich gesagt der herr
flasbarth ihr staatssekretär er lässt
alle verordnungen die die biomethan
branche grad ganz stark bremsen
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich jetzt nicht
fahre dass ich meinen zug wenn sie
jemals bahn gefahren wäre wüsste sie
dass sie sich nicht beeilen muss
herr schulze auf dem falschen fuß
erwischt
immerhin sehen wir das positive es
passiert endlich was im verkehrssektor
stellen sie sich vor sogar mercedes benz
wird jetzt grün mercedes benz der
konzern hat angekündigt in drei jahren
nur noch co2 neutral zu produzieren also
bei der autoherstellung auf kohlestrom
zu verzichten wir schalten live nach
stuttgart zur neuen fair gehandelten
unternehmenssprecherin würde schneider
frau schneider ausgerechnet mercedes
wird jetzt ein öko laden herberge was
heißt denn ausgerechnet mercedes hier
die zum nachhaltigkeit um unseren
planeten heißt ja nicht umsonst wir
haben den slk mit v8 turbo von unseren
kindern nur geleast
den kann ich habe ja irgendwann muss man
das mal begreifen welche die zeit
effekten verbrenner kisten ist doch
vorbei
die zukunft gehört kleinen nachhaltigen
mobilitätskonzepten wie unserem neuen
eco c dem ersten rein elektrischen suv
wiegt schlanke zweieinhalb tonnen und
hat 408 ps
genießen sie das gute gefühl eisbären zu
retten
während sie nachhaltig auf der linken
spur durch deutschland kacheln
serienmäßig dazu gibt es diesen duft bau
mit hirse lavendel aroma für unsere
weiblichen kunden haben wir natürlich
auch einen bericht nach robert habeck
unterm arm
[Applaus]
klimaschutz konstrukt ja zweieinhalb
tonnen suv
da muss man wohl rund 200.000 kilometer
fahren um eine bessere co2 bilanz als
ein diesel zu haben
naja ein suv ausschuss sei gerade wenn
bald der meeresspiegel steigt dann will
man natürlich höher sitzen und wie viel
co2 der wirklich verbraucht strom völlig
egal
wir können den laut eu mit null
emissionen in unseren flottenverbrauch
einrechnen
als ob sie sagen ich habe zehn kilo
abgenommen weil meine frau ins
fitnessstudio geht also ich freue mich
ja über euer neues öko image aber ist
der konzern ich gerade erst mit neuer
abgas schummel software bei 60.000
diesel suvs erwischt worden wie sie herr
welke das haben doch alles längst aus
der welt geräumt
also nicht den vorwurf aber die software
daimler hatte bei der aufklärung
versprochen alle tricksereien den
behörden zu melden
doch schwieg über diese schummel
software und begann offenbar sie
heimlich bei werkstattbesuchen zu
löschen
ja und man muss doch den kunden nicht
mit jedem detail belästigen
im fernsehen laufen schon so viele
meldungen die den menschen angst machen
handelskrieg thomas gottschalk macht
wieder wetten dass wir von mercedes benz
sind jetzt nachhaltig punkt ab sofort
wird sogar die mercedes benz schule
software vollkommen klimaneutral
programmiert nun emissionen
und keine angst wenn der fahrradfahrer
nicht mehr kann vergären wir ihn zu
biomethan chronologisch über schlager
oder mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt das xenix ein beschissenes
ab
[Musik]